It turns.
So explain to me how you make the multiplication tables with your hands?
Well then it is necessary We start from the principle that We know all
our multiplication tables from 1 to 5,
which includes the 2×3 4×4 up to 5,
5×5 And in fact,
we carry on our hands all the multiplication tables from 5.
So for example if uh Uh I make you Uh The simplest is 7×7,
we do like that,
we do like we already have 5,
so 7 is plus 2 Here And we do 7×7 And we read the answer in our hands.
All fingers raised are worth 10,
so that's 10 20 30,
40 And fingers bent,
we multiply them one by the other.
Hence the interest of knowing these steps from up to 5.
So that's 10 20 30 40+3 times 3 49 Now I do with 1 other
I do uh Uh 6×8 6×8 that's 10 20 30 40+4 times 2,
48.
If I do 9×7,
um 9×7,
that's 1020304050 60+3 times 1,
63 And the funny one is 6×7 because 6×7 it's a little because it's 6×7,
that's 30+4 times 3,
12,
30+12,
that's 42,
6×7 42 It works great and And I never understood why the kids,
uh We didn't teach them this technique.
Rather struggle with all the tables of It is enough to know these
tables from 1 to 5 and after all the rest is on our hands.
If I make 9×9,
that's eighty plus 1×1 1 81 That's it.